Sau nhiều ngày cơ động liên tục chết biển trong được kịch sống to só lưỡn tất tập.
Đầu khu một năm trận đạo mà đoàn công tác của hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam
đã gặp cả thích nào để xin đồng chủ quốc
mắt đầu trước trình thăm xa dạo chủ quốc.
Tại cảnh thích nào đóng đoàn hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam
có đại dịt hạc đồ mắc khai,
tuyệt hủ và mắt nhạc của khại quân dại phóng nhân dân chủ quốc.
Sau lễ đó, được tổ chết chọt thì đoàn công tác của hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam
đã mời các cám bộ xí quân của hạc đối mắc khai
lên thăm tạo có 1 năm trận đạo.
Hại bên thống nhất trên trình làm việc
và một số hả nọng sau lê u thể thao vàn hóa,
ẩm thực kết hợp lễ tập trung trong thại sản đoàn công tác của hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam
thăm xa dạo chủ quốc từ ngày 1 mộ đến hết ngày 1 mộn
tức mởi hai.
Né là lần thứ hai tạo có 1 năm trận đạo
này dịt của hại quân nhân dân Việt Nam
thăm xa dạo và nước chủ quốc nhạc bản hàed quốc
gói vân khẳng này tinh thần đoàn kết hướng bị hợp tác
cùng hại quân cách nước trong châu lục và chế thế giới
xây dự buộc bản hòa bình phát triển.